[Music]
are you ready squirrel friends the
season 12 cast of RuPaul's Drag Race has
just been revealed I'm still trying to
digest everything but what I do know
it's going to be an epic 12th season
my fellow Americans RuPaul's Drag Race
Season 12 is here and mama Roos needs
to pledge allegiance to the drive in a
recent interview with Entertainment
Weekly RuPaul said our producers have
come up with twisted outrageous
challenges that raise the bar for all
competition of reality adding our
celebrity guest judges are truly
legendary and this cast of Queens is
dare I say the most talented we've ever
had just when you think you've seen it
all a fresh crop of Queens arrives and
blows our minds all over again gooped
most talented
let's hope they all have that charisma
uniqueness nerve and talent to back that
statement up now another thing I noticed
is that five yes five of the 13 Queens
are from New York so you can expect them
to all be gagged when they walk into
that workroom and see each other
will there be past drama between the New
York Queens yeah I'm almost sure of it
13 also a few of the Queens have
celebrity connections
remember when Adele and Jennifer
Lawrence were spotted at a drag bar in
New York City well they went to see
Brita filter Berta says that Adele asked
her to do her birthday party and
Jennifer wanted her to do her
Bachelorette but she couldn't because
she was filming season 12
another Queen Dalia sin' has a famous
drag mother she's perfect she's
beautiful she is from the house of Asia
did you stone those tight oh you're
smiling
they eat her up every single time she's
on that damn stage she can walk out
there in a diaper JanSport may look
familiar to you
she's been on America's Got Talent
before as part of a trio Stephanie's
child the group actually got into a
little fight with Simon Cowell for me I
couldn't listen to that screaming any
longer I mean whoever was doing the
height thing
look it's just my opinion I love a wrong
opinion don't you girls
[Applause]
it also looks like we have a wide
variety of drag aesthetics being
represented on the show from the spooky
Queens to the comedy Queens to the
fashion Queens season 12 looks like it
has it all
alright I still have to take all of this
in I cannot wait I know you can't either
so what do you think of the new crop of
Queens who do you think is a front
runner to win season 12 do you think
we'll see a route turning Queen come
back to the workroom as a 14th
competitor
if so who let me know in the comments
below and don't forget to subscribe to
ET Canada's YouTube page
[Music]